the given channel is designed to pass a
flood of 2500 CFS at a depth of 8 ft
under uniform velocity which answer is
closest to the minimum required width
for each of the two overbank sections in
order to achieve this so what we've got
here is a Channel with a depth of 3T
plus 5T is our 8 ft over here and the
whole Channel plus the overbank group of
sections together is meant to pass a
flow of 2500
CFS the slope is going to be
0.01 and we have different Mannings n
values for the over Banks versus the
channel the problem is asking us to find
how much width each overbank needs to be
to pass the total flow
required so the first thing we would
need to do is find
the amount of flow that just the channel
itself can pass so
Manning's equation comes to mind
immediately for that when I see open
Channel flow typically I think of
Mannings anyway so open
Channel
think
Mannings okay so let's write out our
Mannings equation which is from page
345 on the reference
manual so we've got Q
= 1.
1486 /
n a a over
PW to the
2/3 s to
the2 and that's going to be the
hydraulic radius just expand it a little
more so note here that the width is a
function or is one of the components
rather that goes into area and goes into
wed perimeter so we're going to be
playing with these terms to solve for
the correct amount of flow once we know
how much flow the channel itself can
pass so first let's find the flow in the
channel so we've got Q
equals
1.4
86 Over N = 0.0
4 area is going to be 40 * we're going
to do the whole height of the channel so
8 so that's 40t *
8T and then area again 40 ft * 8
ft
over the wetted perimeter is only the
area in contact with the channel bottom
so we're going to have 3 + 40 + 3
the rest of this doesn't have a
frictional force from the wall
associated with it so that's going to
be and all of those are in
feet all of that is to the
2/3 and the slope we know is
0.001 square root so if we solve out for
this we're going to get a q
of just
about
1370 cubic feet per
second so next step is how much
flow does the overbank need to pass so
if we have a total of
minus
1370 cubic feet per second that means
the over banks will need to channel just
about
CFS now because there's two over
Banks now because there's two over Banks
we're going to need to solve for one of
the
widths but really what we're saying
is now because there's two over
Banks this really means that each one
needs to handle half of the
flow so the way we could write this out
is
[Music]
that
11:30 cubic feet per second equals so
we're going to write out Mannings again
1.4
86 over the Manning Zen for the overbank
is 0.1 five so it's much rougher than
the channel
itself now the area here is going to
be we don't know the width but we do
know the height is five because that's
what we need to keep the channel at a
total depth of eight which was asked by
the problem so we're going to say 5 * W
here and then same thing here for the
area over wed perimeter equation we have
5 * w
over W + 5 because that's the total area
in contact with the overbank section so
w +
5 all of that to the
2/3 and our slope we at least know
because that's consistent with the
channel so that's going to
be the square root of
0.1 and because because we have two
overbank sections needed for the total
flow here we can actually multiply that
whole thing by
two
so this is where we get to a point in
the problem where we can simplify a
little bit but it's going to be really
difficult and timec consuming if to try
to solve for w by itself and with the
calculator you have on the exam it might
not even really be possible to do that
without a lot of additional steps
so at this point it Mak makes more sense
to we can simplify it a little bit so
let's let's remove any of these free
terms here that aren impacted by a the W
variable so if we go to step four over
here we can say that if we multiply by
0.15 divide by 1.48
6 divide by the slope and divide by two
we should get
equal 5 *
w 5 *
W over W +
5 to the
23 which if you want to rewrite that one
more time you could say 5 *
W to the
5/3
over W + 5
to the 2/3
equals is supposed to equal
1803 so at this point the way to do this
is to test your
answers
so let's
assume that W equals 125 since that's
one of the two middle terms to start
with so if W equal
125 we could plug that into here
and 5 *
125 to the
over
125 +
5 to the
2/3 and solving that in your calculator
should be doable enough and that's going
to get us to about
1780 which is
is very close relatively speaking
to 1803 which was what we were solving
for after manipulating around this
equation over
here so we can believe here that 125 is
going to be the right answer because
anything less is going to get you
farther away from 1803 and doubling the
width is going to greatly exceed that
value so our answer here is 125 ft for
the width of each overbank section
because remember we multiplied the
entire Mannings equation over here by
two to account for each
overbank so all you have to know for
this problem is to break up the channel
to use Manning's equation to break up
the channel into the channel and the
over Banks and then at the end to try to
solve to guess and check your W's rather
than solve for that directly and that
should be it